hi shelby hi steve so
today we are going to
hit the um 20
you know the lessons past 20. so we're
now going to be dealing with a range
of tenses very exciting
so we'll see how we cope with it um
you know it's funny you know in
different languages like in arabic
they begin with the past tense like
there's no real reason why the present
tense is easier than the past tense
sure i think it's just that it's more
common maybe or like applicable
uh immediately applicable right like i
can just say i am sitting here right now
right but but the strange thing is that
in arabic
because the past tense is for whatever
reason they start with the past tense
that's the first tense that they teach
that is so there's only two tenses
the two tenses there's the past and the
present i mean i exaggerated but yeah
so i mean we take certain things for
granted that languages can only be
structured this way
but different languages are are
different yeah absolutely
um so and and i i think very often sort
of grammar
books can make things seem more
complicated
than they need to be i just relate it to
meaning this means this
that's all i know what it means in
english here's how you say it in french
okay yeah i am when i was living in
south america
i befriended a lot of um
you know people from south america some
of which who love
languages and actually spend time you
know learning other languages
and they understand their own language
better so i like to ask a lot of
questions you know
why is it like this you know what why do
we do it that
why do you guys say it that way etc and
the ones who are really
interested in language like they can
usually have some sort of an answer for
me
or they might even say that's so
interesting i haven't thought of it
before
you know like right and then you know i
meet someone who's
so not interested in language he's a
native speaker of spanish and i ask him
these questions
why this why that about spanish and he's
like i don't know
never thought about it you know so
depending on
how interested you are in the language
you might have a deeper understanding
and explanation for why things
are but you can also just speak a
language
and not know why things are the way they
are but you are still
a perfect speaker and understander of
that language so
of course i mean you can always google
you know if
there's a certain term in spanish or a
structure that
seems strange you can google and get an
explanation but oh sure but it's just
for conversation
yeah for conversation so in english for
example do you how many
english speakers native speakers of
english have
ever heard the term modal verbs
i don't even think i've heard that term
before
every foreigner learning english knows
the term modal verbs i wouldn't say
everybody's quite common
interesting and so yeah and all of the
you know english
grammar books are full of it and all
modal m-o-d-a-l
it's somebody's technical term for
i might i would i should i could i ought
to
any of those verbs that suggest
an obligation or a possibility or you
know
all of that those are called modal verbs
interesting
my view is why introduce the term modal
verbs it's just
unnecessary right you have to the
concept i
ought to might should they exist in
every language
in in some languages there's more of
them or fewer of them
like some languages there's no
difference between probably and maybe
in english we have probably and maybe
like different languages have different
you know maybe in a lot of languages
ought to should
have to is all one verb maybe maybe not
so you just get used to what they do so
i i think that
all these grammatical terms are
tremendous overkill
uh and it's it's ultimately a matter of
like
this is how they say it in this language
and this is what it means in
either my native language or a language
that i know very well
right so you relate them yeah and you
know
just because you know what modal verbs
are doesn't mean you're going to be a
perfect user
of them and just like uh you know i
don't know what modal verbs are yet i'm
sure
i'm probably using them correctly being
a native english speaker
so that's a distraction though right
like it can be a distraction to think
like
you have to learn the name of the tense
you know and you think that you
understand or you're you're making
progress in the language and you might
be but at the same time
even if i don't know the name of the
tense i'm using but i'm using it
correctly
i'm probably making more progress right
than the person who knows the name of
the tents
no that's not to say that we should
ignore those things but i remember when
i was learning german
trying to memorize these declension
tables basically discouraged me
and it was only when i stopped doing
that and just started listening and
reading and picking up words and
using the language that i started to be
able to speak the language so
i think there could be you know there
can be sort of overkill
uh you know on those things and it can
be intimidating i remember
like in arabic to tell you something
like there's seven kinds of verbs and
they give you a whole bunch of
explanation now you'll skip that because
it's
there's no way i'm gonna learn that so
but i manage i understand and the more i
listen the more i understand
the more i'm able to say so therefore
i say that because we're going to head
into you know a variety of tenses now
and so it's going to be very interesting
how you react
and i think you may find that as long as
you get the meaning and of course you
can look up
uh now on your uh you know i think
context reversal conjugation
or the other conjugating dictionary you
can see where it slots in which one it
is
you have a quick review of the verbs
don't try to remember it and get back
the text
and just keep doing that and eventually
you'll get a sense of how these
forms of the verb are used and what they
correspond to in english
i think yeah but we will see i've gotten
a preview of
past tense and some of the you know
liberty plants and some of the songs
so of course starting to get my hints
as to what it's gonna be like well sure
and if you're interested in those
uh contents then you're not bothered by
the fact that in fact it's in the past
tense that's what the story is
yeah you can tell from the context it's
the past tense they said it this way
and you continue through your story and
it's it's not an obstacle yeah and i
don't feel too nervous about it with
french it seems like it's fairly
straightforward
i'm noticing the same pattern every time
so yeah
it's straightforward because you know
spanish and english now if you were a
japanese speaker with no previous
exposure to european languages you might
find
it a little more complicated but
nevertheless still it relates back to
what you know rather than to some
rule of course yeah okay well let's give
it a try then all right sounds good
hi so we're gonna venture into uh
different tenses yes so you said um at
20 or
no after 20. after 20. all right i'm
gonna go for 21
by the way just in case you think that
21 is a lot easier than 30
not so all these are more or less the
same i find
i think language there's no chapter one
chapter two it's all different
it's all difficult it's all easy it's
all more or less the same stuff and
and we go after with each lesson we go
after you know little snippets of it we
try to learn that
but that has application for the whole
language because we're going over the
same structures
so i think you'll find you'll be
surprised that it's not so difficult
also i should add because uh we should
go to the the part b
because it looks like the part a is all
in the present tense
i was gonna say i don't see any anything
other than present tense yet
right so uh we'll move along now
because you're flipping through these i
don't know what your settings are but
it's possible you're eliminating all
your blue words
no i have my link reader settings set to
not
mark the words as known uh when i page
okay just a couple of things
yeah so reminding people that they can
set it to either automatically be saved
or not but even if they do get
automatically saved that doesn't prevent
you from saving them again
and the the statistics adjust so it's
not a big issue
but yeah in your settings page paging
moves to known you have
untick ticked it that's good yeah
definitely recommend people
mess around with these settings to make
them work best for them
okay so okay so and
here is where we start the yeah
different tenses okay let's do that
sentence is
in the same present tense but it still
tells us what's happening this is the
same story but from michael's point of
view
yeah read it in french
yeah okay
yeah that sounds like a great uh phrase
to have there
and then view view or cite
either one yeah
yeah i mean if a view site i mean yeah
it's the same
yeah great okay and debris is uh
important word uh you'll come across
that again it's
from or since oh yeah i was going to say
since i only had that as since that
didn't really make sense to me but okay
that makes more sense now okay and then
means here is like look here is okay
okay great
so what have we got here all right
we're in the past tense
[Music]
again a native speaker might correct me
but i don't think we would
have liaisons we could say that but i
think it's jp
yeah that was a tough one i wasn't i
wasn't let's hear what she says
let's hear what our rapid fire narrator
says
rely on him and you got a new voice okay
okay okay all right so
why don't we save jp save
jpl yeah i took
okay and then
that sounds like is that not a is that a
common phrase
yes it is they are great if you click on
commentary
so yeah i guess i had that from a
different story
right so a day of a day of leave a day
off a day of leave
but if we go back to p p r i s uh-huh
let's go to that conjugating dictionary
all right
from the verb poem right very popular
verb
right quantity now let's see if we can
find p
ah there we have it
okay so i don't want to get too much
stuff here but
it's you see where it says passe sample
yeah
you can forget it's really interesting
you can forget that like people use this
in french no
that's exclusively in literature
so if you are reading a novel you'll see
that
otherwise you'll never see it so it's
like improper to use that and
not it's it's just not used it's not
improv it would be silly it would be
pretentious
it's just not used in speech
so to me that's one of the things i
would just put a shelf somewhere because
you're not going to need it for six
months just forget about it
that's great makes it a little bit
simpler for me
now we see the passe compose we see the
passenger
all these different forms of the past
tense the significant thing is that the
p
p r i s is the
past part whatever it's called yeah past
particular like
talk right uh-huh so i took i
had ten english ago i had taken
yeah but i would have taken but
in french it's the same word i love that
so it's just the past participle that's
great so the passe composer
in the middle there that is the most
common past tense
well there's also the imperfect but
we'll get there okay so that's
i took so jp so it doesn't matter news
have won p like it conjugates like
like the only thing that actually
changes is the verb what we call the
auxiliary verb the avoir right
jp grp etc
okay
okay
now here we have the uh
you know the whole issue of the
imperfect versus the
composer right so you could also have
said
i wanted but i wanted to go and see a
film
they tend to use the imperfect more than
we we would not say i was one
i was wanting to go and see a film you
wouldn't say that yeah
i understood this as i would like to
no okay that's
again there's nothing wrong with uh with
guessing
i find that i guess and most often i
guess wrong that's why i looked them up
people sometimes say oh you should try
and guess and stuff i don't i look it up
because my guess is going to be wrong 50
of them that's my experience because you
have nothing to
base it on your chances are your guess
will be wrong
so there again like with me if i get
into this
20 nb or 21 and beyond all kinds of
different verb forms every single one of
them i'm going to look up
the context reversal conjugated yeah and
i definitely
i guess i had marked that word as known
unknowingly that was dangerous okay
well you see it's the imperfect right
no way you're going to remember that but
i always look at it and then i just
leave it i don't try to memorize it
and in time and you see it in different
contexts
and you'll still get it wrong but there
it is
and sometimes if i go to voulez like we
need to go there now but
i would also look at the pasek composite
just to see the two of them
you see so if you want to conjugate her
again
and so you see that's your vole but if
you look at the pasek jose you see
yeah yeah i don't even think i've
come across that yet no but it's it's
just kind of helps
slowly slowly you know all that
everything starts to
slot into place so i find this
conjugating dictionary a great place to
go
i'm not a believer and there's some
research in cognitive
science etc that trying to block learn
something is very difficult
and it's much easier to come across it
in different situations so you see it in
the text you review it in the table you
see it in another text you review it in
the table again
and slowly like sediments it settles
into your brain whereas if you sat there
with the conjugation table
i'm gonna learn this you know and then
i'm gonna put it on my
refrigerator door
that's gonna be useful that's uh a
futile exercise in my opinion
anyway okay we'll do one more
all right oh lots of blue
here it's all but it's all in the
present tense so with that
i suggest we stop okay because that's
just your standard activity you're going
to go in there you're going to find by
the way that
most of the blue words there are
cognates looks like it
oh it's not difficult all together
right but i just wanted to expose you a
little bit to
uh yeah different tenses so we'll come
across some future we'll come across
some past
and i just recommend that you refer to
the conjugated dictionary from time to
time just to kind of
keep that little picture in front of you
great
[Laughter]
[Music]
salute
[Music]
you